the mass exodus presses on as the u.s
military oversees flights taking
americans and afghan allies out of
taliban-controlled kabul a flight packed
with hundreds of babies children and the
elderly landed early this morning in
albania another is due to arrive in
philadelphia
charlie dagetta has the latest from doha
cutter on the persian gulf the first
stop for many americans and afghans from
that airlift charlie good morning
good morning yes this country has taken
in around 40 000 arrivals from kabul
already and counting but around kabul
airport itself this morning there are
growing concerns as to whether isis is
intent on retaliating for that airstrike
the military operation on track to
become the largest airlift in american
history is now just three days from
coming to an end
but it's entering the most perilous
period yet and that threat is acute it
is ongoing
our troops are still in danger and they
are taking the steps they are taking to
save lives and evacuate people because
of their commitment to the mission a
mission now complicated after that
retaliation u.s drone strike centcom
said the reaper strike launch from an
undisclosed location in the middle east
targeted nangahar province the heartland
of isis in eastern afghanistan near the
border with pakistan
a region well known to u.s and afghan
forces who've conducted multiple joint
operations against the terrorist
organization in recent years
armed taliban militants have beefed up
security around the airport since that
devastating bomb attack that killed more
than 170 people but they're accused of
no longer allowing afghan nationals to
leave the country
most of the european coalition flights
and their forces have already left and
while the white house says there are
around 500 u.s citizens who want to
leave there were no details provided on
exactly how or when that's going to
happen
one key question is how many americans
are already inside the airport because
another warning has been issued advising
all u.s citizens to avoid coming to the
airport and anybody outside the gates
should leave immediately
dana
charlie thank you